this is the bismillah hamdulillah so I'm
making peace be with you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show today we're gonna be answering one
of your questions so don't go anywhere
I got something to read to you so we can
all benefit when we come back here in
Adi show
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
why are you come sit down Ruffalo hey
Kareem here on the Deen show how are you
how are things in Denver peaceful
peaceful hamdulillah now some people
think that you know Muslims are bringing
havoc so they're trying to you know get
people all wild up wound up and scared
but we started with peace you said it's
peaceful I'm Muslim bringing peace or
they bring havoc a Muslim must bring
peace whatever he is must be with a
smile must be that's how we should be we
shouldn't be just like Salaam alaikum no
you see Salaam is is is the word but it
really also you must carry the spirit of
it Salam means peace
so not only the word your other have to
carry the spirit of peace and you know
that's how the prophets Allah an asylum
you know was and this is how he
penetrated hearts because of that
peaceful approach of of about things and
to others and I know it's hard you know
it's it's hard sometimes we we all get
tested we all go through hardship
hardships but do it for the sake of
Allah do it for the sake of Allah
because whenever you carry that name
Mohamed Ahmed they smile a Muslim name
or you have their appearance and look of
a Muslim you're presenting Islam and
this is what will make a difference
eddy in here if we you see a lot of
people are asking why the Dawa is not
reaching its goal here we've been trying
within our numbers are increasing why I
told him this I will work also deal of
the Aloha or - Buhari at one stage
actually he decided to leave Mecca
because again he was going through the
oppression and injustice of non-muslims
at the very beginning so he arrived a
place called Jeddah and any of the red
sea about to take a ship and go to
Abyssinia so one of the non-muslims
kafir non-muslims he was actually one of
them
leaders of the tribe in the Arabia his
name is Abner didn't say you girl Cara
he's the leader of a tribe called Ankara
so he saw him by the seaside and he's
about to get into position what are you
going about I'm leaving Makkah
I cannot worship Allah friendly I'm
going through you know I'm I can't wear
my hijab for a Muslim woman in America I
cannot you know have the look of a
Muslim you know having a beer then and
because I'm singled out and I'm I lose
my job if I pray and so forth you know
what the this non-muslim said to have a
walker so do you know what he said to
him miss look life would wanna encourage
someone like you should not leave no he
should be expelled why he said because
you're generous to your guests you stand
for the truth and you help the needy he
mentioned his character you see other
Muslim care less how many are Acacio
pray at night whether his doctor him I'm
not belittling this so please don't
misunderstand me but he looks at your
characters who are you on the side you
know booth at agra ferry the companion
he used to live in before he was one of
the Companions by the way who worship
Allah call him to the middle of Ibraheem
and he heard about this message this
person in Mecca claiming that he is a
messenger say no Muhammad's Allah Allah
he doesn't know he heard a rumor that
there is somebody in Mecca is claiming
that he's a prophet so he had a brother
his name is oh nice he said yeah hey
he's going to check this man out for me
so when I swing to Mecca and he sat
around the Kaaba and he's watching the
Prophet he came back to a border and he
told him one statement or ie Torah julen
yeah a movie Meharry me luck
I saw a man whose book on landing good
good character yes so we got good
character people who are having good
carry are not spreading havoc now there
are people like who are calling to peace
Muslims right and Islam means peace
meaning if you want to get peace you got
to submit to the owner peace right
and this is what it's all about right
yeah so that's what will make the
difference in the end of the day so yeah
I must say peace mm-hmm I must you know
somehow Allah we tried plastic sometimes
sometimes you have to do it plastic
begin with a plastic yeah you know more
plastic plastic and then it ends up to
be and then I'll be natural it becomes
natural
so this yeah this is what the Muslims
are about yeah so tell us now now I got
the question oh when you show and I said
look we got to read the question so
you're the person has qualified God
willing a lot of help give us some
advice people go to doctors if they have
a disease and something but many of us
we have the disease of the heart and
this is more important because the pills
might fix you up and you might heal your
bone if it's broke but man when the
heart is rusted it needs that polish
polish so let's get some polish tell us
the sister look I think if she says that
message love your show
sister needs a push title okay so she
said for years my husband has been
growing and improving in his Dean Dean
the way of life of all the messengers of
God Islam so and for years he has been
nicely trying to get me to wear the
hijab that's the fashion from the seven
heavens from the crater right so he's
been for you trying to get me to wear
two hijab and for years I've refused I
just can't seem to find the courage to
wear it my parents are Muslims more
cultural in brackets it says and it's
strange but they are against the hijab
also and I feel they would disown me if
I put it on I'm also nervous as to how
my friends friends would react it's
eating away at me and I feel Allah the
Creator keeps sending me signs now the
question is am I being ungrateful by not
wearing it
what about my parents what am I gonna do
that's the question Sheikh let's turn
this into a program I thought you know
we can discuss this and inshallah at the
end the sister will shed a tear her
heart will soften and she's gonna run
and put that can I can I tell you
something that I think I've done in a
previous show with you but here it is
again the religion is create a feed and
Sherea Sherea is loose commands the
hijab is the Sharia law alone but the
art eat is missing here and the heart of
my sister and I'm not being
mental offer but you know we all need
knowledge I wanna I wanna I wanna base
this on on a story the story of the high
jump
I shall be Allah on is the narrator of
this one
she says this when the verse
regarding the command for the women to
wear the hijab was revealed colossal and
solitude as a solo number 33 yeah you
had maybe you could lay as well jacoba
not iike when he said I mean I would
mean Ali Hinnom Angelababy Hannah
directed not novella Dinah lie because a
lot of the viewers they say the hijab is
not in the Quran lets in the Quran the
immigrants the women the wives of the
immigrants as soon as this verse was
revealed you know out of women they used
to have around them something called an
untucked
something that they wrap around their
waist they tore this and they cover it
right away then it hesitate you know
because a command from Allah so they
were connected with Allah yes
they knew that you have to please al I
have no choice well may I can only move
meaning male Amina look at this first
Eddie look at this verse sister I hope
you're watching us it is not befitting
for someone who want to be a believer
whether he is male or female when Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala decides a matter then
they have a choice they have a choice no
choice you have no choice sister I think
a lot of our Muslim sisters they think
hey job is just a religious symbol like
the cross and Christianity order they
call this what Monica Monica yeah the
hijab is a religious requirement for a
Muslim sister it's like praying five
times a day you have no choice
it is not befitting for a believing man
or a believing woman when Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala commands you to do something
that you have a choice that you have an
option
or you're intimidated by other people
unless if your life is threatened that's
another issue but you're afraid now that
you're going to displease your family
but meanwhile you are displeasing Allah
I tell you my sister your family will
find other ways to be displeased with
you and I've is this on also in an
authentic hadith the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi salam says if you try to
displease a lot if you displease allah
or here it is when our beneficent allah
if you try to please people at the
expense of the displeasure of allah
allah subhana allah will make those
people displeased with you I see that
you need to take a break but here it is
sister please allah subhana wa ta'ala
and you will see that your family will
be behind you on this allah will make
them pleased with you
that's we're going to get to rest of the
hadith when we come back and in messages
no more anywhere we'll be right back do
you think these things are going to
bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain what we are offering in Islam
what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
are at peace they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if I'm honest I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid
back here on the Dean show the special
guests Shay Kareem Imam in Denver and
you deal with these issues all the time
you've been in mom a long time you know
and we want to get from your knowledge
so we can benefit and so inshallah we
can implement and we can do this way of
life Islam submission to the will of God
so we can avoid the Hellfire because
death is a reality and we want to get to
Jenna and the way to get there is to
please our creative before we meet our
crater and now we're talking about we're
answering a question sister wants to
push she wants this encouragement so
we're giving it inshallah so you
mentioned that hadith continue from
there if you work to to please the
people at the expense of displeasing
Allah Allah be displeased if you hate it
here is what it says yeah men out of the
nests at the soccer field laugh
whosoever tries to please people and
regardless whoever it is it whether you
you mentioned your family in your
question family friends so you're trying
to please your family and your friends
but add the expense of the displeasure
of Allah you see we need to understand
that the concept of me loving you and
I'm loving you it's it's not we have
really nothing to do with it and that
maybe you need to try to explain that
concept in a minute
you see we love with that limb right the
heart isn't that yes I mean I will love
you with the hand I just you know I love
you with the heart okay can I say this
my heart I want you to love Eddie can I
do it can I do this no it doesn't work
this way actually the one who directs
your heart to love a person is the one
who holds the hearts the Prophet
sallallaahu ah do sell them and hadith
Abdullah have nominal our society Muslim
he says in not pollute of any and
another a no swine demon Assad they are
rough man the horse of the children Adam
are two fingers of the fingers of Allah
we believe that Allah has fingers we
believe that but how they look like we
don't know should we visualize that now
we don't so it's nothing like his
nothing is like him nothing is like him
and whatever you visualize is beyond
that ladies a chemically shake so our
heart this is defined out what you just
said from the current lays a committal
eje secondly he shade there is nothing
like a loss there's nothing like a long
nose not nothing like Allah once it
comes
his essence nothing like Allah once it
comes to his actions
nothing like Allah once it comes to his
name's what nothing like allowance it
comes to his attributes he's he don't
look like us we don't look like no no
you don't compare a lot to any of his
creation lemmya cool of Khufu and a hat
well I'm me I could love ohkawa not so
yes our hearts are between two fingers
of Allah he rotates them the way that he
wants here is that concept of love works
sister listen to this how'd it feel for
Harry I did a betrayal
Adi Allah and the Prophet sallallaahu
Hollywood celebs says if the I have the
law who arrived then gibreel if Allah
loves the servant of his he will call up
when he breathes deeply ill the
Archangel Gabriel had a whole pond rd in
the prophets of loss and I'm saw him at
one stage 600 wings he blocked the
horizon
Yeji breathe or debris in knee or hip
bufala and a nip enough for that I love
so the son of soul imagine Allah saying
your name you know in Facebook right now
you know they get you get these messages
this person mentioned your name you get
excited you get excited you're right and
you imagine large mom Allah mentioning
your name yeah somebody really is you
know a companion his name is oh babe the
car how do you feel more Harry Keitt
double tough see the prophets Allah son
I'm calling upon him and he said yeah
obey obey away in the Sahaba the
companion the one who led the fellow we
had the time for homework with the
Muslims and tear away
yeah obey in Aloha I'm irani and accra
Alec Isola television Allah command me
to recite to you so that he'll be in la
mia cowan lady naka for man you know
basis ya rasulallah almost as a man
you're not luck did Allah name me to you
Who am I for a lot to Debbie for imagine
sister of Allah loves you he will call
upon G breed I love so the daughter of
so Gabriel of Gabriel will call upon the
dwellers of the heavens in Ramallah the
angels Allah loves so-and-so I want you
to love them here it is hidden offer to
mrudula whole Kabul floor then the
acceptance of that person will be placed
in the hearts of the believers in earth
but now
how will Allah love you when you are
disobeying come on let's make sense how
just please Allah span out that and at
the end of the day if you see the
pleasure of Allah Allah will get the
people like in you your family will like
you your family will love you and this
is what is meant by this hadith man our
Vanessa be so happy let whoever tries to
please people at the expense of Allah
than this pleasure of Allah Allah will
turn their hearts against that person
woman us her tenacity read Allah
Catahoula goodness and if you end up
making people unhappy because you're
trying to please your Lord the Prophet
did not say that Allah is going to make
them no he said Allah will protect you
from the people they are not gonna harm
you
yes we love our parents yes we like our
friends we like they would like to be
accepted by them there is no question
about it but listen laughs ah I tell him
a fluke in FEMA Seattle howl there is no
human being entitled to avoid obedience
which comes at the expense of the
disobedience of Allah is as simple as
that we kill the sister come on do it do
it for the sake of Allah like you said
this world is so short you always say it
was here saying that it is so short we
could die tomorrow
yeah often you dying tomorrow without a
hijab Allah will ask you about why
because I was trying to please my my
friends and trying to please the society
I'm trying to please my family I'm
telling you this answer is not gonna pay
off now what can the the brother do also
because we look at the sisters but let's
take to account some of the husbands
also so let's say the husband at home
should he be making his house and
environment of Quran he makes his house
now let's say he wants his wife to wear
hijab but he's got you know baseball
football and Xbox all day have you don't
hear that and let's say he's like coming
around but at the same time look we
don't want again like be judgemental and
we've been gentle with this obviously
because we love you know so we love the
people so we want to you know give the
best advice so what about the brother
now also should he be making more
talking more
heydo have been like open up later books
and necessary al-saliheen or some of the
books of knowledge and talking with his
wife mentioning a lot more the Koran
every day maybe have a little Holika in
the morning things like this I don't
know you give us the advice I mean I
will but shall I tell you something that
is relevant to the Hager please tell us
the appearance mm-hmm this is a command
yeah it's a command for it's a command
yeah no question about it
awful yeah Holocaust shared work hard
full you who don't know sir if we're
asking the sister to show like this why
I mean if the brother is shaved and I'm
sorry I mean begin with that okay I
didn't have this but after this you know
establishing your Muslim home like a
Muslim home mm-hmm
we know that the Prophet SAW Allah are
selling banned us from having dogs are
you having dogs at home remove them
pictures why because Allah the knower of
the unseen told us angels will not enter
this house angels will not enter this
house now what is going on with all
these music videos and and CDs and all
that stuff
come on let's work together to have our
Muslim homes established according to
the way of Islam not just the appearance
in the outside when we go outside but
inside the house and also Allah Allah
seldom mentioned that the man is the one
who needs to make these goals so don't
ask the sisters yes to it the hijab when
you are weak in the other end and your
home is not set right to get with hood a
TV
yeah he's TV is March the Deen show
right these are a benefit because the
viewer sitting and watching r-rated
movies you're watching things that have
no benefit you got a whole collection of
DVDs DVDs of all the pop stars these
people are going to help increase your
iman you know it's gonna bring you down
isn't it take you take you down so like
clean these things on and after this
Adia will be asked about this time yeah
time yeah time management oh yeah yeah
no I'm attorney that's the hadith in a
millennium of ruling female calf you
mean a nurse ha ha
well for there are two bounties
regarding which people the majority of
people are losers once it comes to these
two counties because they are not
utilizing them while being healthy that
because when you're healthy you you
you could do more stuff and having time
at your hand now we sit in front of the
TV for two hours three hours watching a
movie
come on you're gonna be asked about this
time in the day of resurrection Allah
will ask you the Prophet hell is Aviv
are zealous let me feel Muslim will
fasten that the feet of the son of Adam
will not move until he's asked about
four things and the other wording five
things about his own word about his life
how did he spend it come here we're
gonna take a break we'll be right back
with more to conclude here in the Deen
show don't go anywhere
death and the day of judgment the mercy
of Allah these are the things that
finally made me realize there is no time
to delay anymore I want you to take
martial heart of right there the essence
of spirituality is to become more
sincere to Allah spend whatever fun to
play death itself it is very very scary
but it brings you back to reality there
is a life which is everlasting if you're
after and you have to make a conscious
decision of which a group of people do
you want to be people in heaven or the
people of hell
back here on addy show and we're
answering the sisters question and we
want to help encourage the people so we
can all be in Jenna together and void
the hellfire and everything that the
crater has told us to do it's good for
us isn't it it is because some people
think Amanda's all rich admits a bunch
of do's and don'ts everything's Haram
Cher everything's I can't no fun now
what do you got to say about this
submission mm-hmm what does it mean
submission submission that you give up
your whims and desires and listen the
religion is so straightforward about it
okay
he said sallalaho aleyh wassallam at
dunya signal movement was a natural
carriage this world is the prison of a
belief in the sense of you don't have
your choices are somehow somewhat
limited but is he you don't understand
there is a kick off you actually find a
happiness and joy and that concept when
you jail yourself when you because at
the end of the day you're trying to
please allah subhana wa ta'ala and like
they say happiness is irrelevant really
it has nothing to do with what you have
it has nothing to do with the person who
smokes
I mean weed for example to be happy for
him to be had to continue to be happy
has to smoke more and more and more and
more he has been crease yeah he has to
double up he has to change the type that
but submission the more that you submit
the same exact thing the more that you
submit to allah subhana wa ta'ala you
find leisure and happiness and it's good
for you isn't it
tell us could we give an example the
person who wants a master's degree a GED
a PhD he's submitting to what the
professor told him to do he's studying
he's leaving off partying he's
sacrificing because he wants that title
so you get the job make money bankroll
and then he can enjoy so aren't we like
living a wholesome good life so at the
end we can get Jenna so we can obey
Allah because aren't these good things
that now the woman's out there flaunting
herself you know she's dressing
provocative man ain't gonna respect her
he's gonna I'm sorry pimp her you know
she's going to be out there you know of
being masqueraded a commodity right just
for man's pleasures and at the same time
look you're drinking smoking weed these
things destroy you so the things lying
deceiving everything that Allah the
Creator told us to do those are things
that are good for us and the things that
he told us to stay away for are just
things that aren't good for the for the
human being isn't that right you know I
go back to that idea
yeah the sister you know no no it shows
to cover this is something very
interesting mentioned in that verse in
surat al-ahzab about the hi Jeff
Derick Edna I mean often FLI oh then
because you brought this up yes so when
the sister wears the hijab and but by
the way the high job is not the scarf
okay
the high job is modesty there are seven
conditions for this a job to exist it
must she must be wearing garments that
is baggy it cannot be of color that gets
attention of me
tight jeans laughs no that's not my job
no you see a sister who places a scarf
on and then five jeans that's not her
job she's just which is us covering her
hair yeah no he job is a concept that
the sister reflected reflecting modest
modesty yes modesty is not getting
attention and I want to go back here to
this point and say a lot of an analysis
so that they are not knowing to be that
type that you mentioned that you can
pick on yeah imagine getting on a metro
or and you find a nun you ever entertain
the thought of flirting with a nun you
might look but you don't keep looking
right you're not even going to think
about the same exact thing for the
sisters for them that is what is meant
so the women cannot be used as a
commodity kind of I'm not saying that
every women and let's be fear not every
woman who dresses this way she's after
that I'm not saying this but there are
wicked people out there and I'm not
saying she's protection yes it's a
protection immunity yes immunity and she
will find pleasure in this world lion
I'll never forget this answer I was in a
seminar I'm sorry in a debate with with
non-muslims and we had Muslim audience
and one of the people asked me this
question about how can you force women
in that hot weather that was we were in
a hot and the summer to dress like this
and I told her I
my best and one of our Muslim sister
asked us to say something she said
exactly what you said a minute ago the
heat of the Hellfire is far worse I
don't other do it here then India well
now who Jahannam I said to her wha lo
can we've gone come on let's submit to
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala this is a
requirement for all Muslim women
that's how Allah subhana and and and
this has been the way it is
since at one of the you know we had this
Yemeni sister who who got that peace
whatever noble was sometimes she made a
very interesting comment and she said
come on guys I mean you talk about the
human race developing you know from
nudity and and and now top of the line
that they actually because how they
present Adam Eve that they were naked
and they were having little things
around their blood is that and then we
they show us in the movies that when
they develop they started dressed and I
reached the top of the line I reached
the top was the Muslim woman who what if
you want to have a piece a Nobel Peace I
mean she said I came to the top now yeah
I'm here with the hijab I read that
statement for non-muslims that's fine I
mean to address non-muslims with yeah
it's fine but you know for me as a
student knowledge I have other ways to
grease them back to people but but I
think she hit it right there come on
guys you you teach in your schools that
Adam and his offspring developed develop
developed and he showed that the top of
the line that they actually got dressed
well guess what I'm covering up yeah and
look at the icon of Maryam the icon
Jesus's mother she all had sisters I
mean Selim and and I want to tell the
sisters this so if any man eliminated
Alam ara Homa Ali Fazal from Shia Muslim
that there are two types of people that
I did not see we know that the Prophet
SAW Salaam went and he saw Jenna and he
saw Hellfire he saw there are two types
of people I did not see in the dunya in
the world date but I saw them in the
Hellfire and he mentioned
walk'n cassia Tatia
yes they were close but they are not
winning anything yeah an icon of
temptation
come on Muslim sister before we go just
we have one minute left Tillis can the
sister now start to okay she's we know
she's she's obviously five pillars you
got to be doing him praying five times a
day where she begun law alone zakat you
know Hajj now for the hijab can she if
she's wearing like tight jeans
okay hey job obviously you mentioned
character okay so doesn't matter now
yours you're in hijab smoke in you know
foul language doesn't work doesn't work
right on this modesty all right so now
can she like leave off the jeans and
start like let's say shitty because
people think is just the covering here
because she just start to wear like the
loose what is it called you know the
Jill Bob yeah you know from here this
loose and then start to work her way up
to progress you know to wearing it she's
like timid baby steps
I I don't want to say this because yes
or just do it you see right now after
the show just put it out across some
soul asylum says this yeah
whatever Allah commands you to do you
need to do it do it do it
I cannot tell somebody pray two times
and then three times and I see I see
yeah so it's a command well uh slow film
here is the people of the basis and a
loss lawful Umbra you Joe idle Hackney
also by default when there is a command
in the Quran and the Sunnah it must be
carried out right away yeah as long as
you don't have something an obstacle
that stops you yeah your ability that's
the rule Thank You Sheikh so much thank
you I'd be like my lover word you but I
look forward to having you back again
and some more great wonderful advice and
for our sisters we love you but a lot
loves you the most he loves you more
than your parents he loves you more than
anyone and he knows what's best for you
so let's work hard in this life to
please our Creator before we meet our
Creator because death is a reality and
then there's the day of judgment and
then there's the Hellfire and paradise
so want to be people of paradise allows
the most loving and merciful make go out
to him repent to him alone no
intermediaries we don't need to go to a
confession box we don't need to pray
through anybody
direct dial up we call on the crater
alone
and ask him to make it easy and commit
and believe me Allah will facilitate a
way get up in the night and pray one
tear Allah will open up doors you
couldn't even imagine because he loves
you but do you love him that's the
question if you love them you got to
obey Him so let's work hard in this life
so we can be successful in this life
they have Jenna in the next we'll see
you next time here and the Deen show
don't forget to pick up the new dunya -
Deen and call us at